all right we are officially one week
away from the first round of the nfl
draft yeah and we're expecting hundreds
of thousands of football fans to descend
on the strip but we know locals don't
want to miss out either john treach has
more on ways you can maximize the draft
day experience
hey there kirsten yeah for the first
time ever the nfl has entrusted one city
with their three marquee events we
already hosted the pro bowl the super
bowl is coming in less than two years
and yes that great nfl draft comes to
our city next week but we want locals to
be able to experience that showcase
experience the spotlight of las vegas
boulevard but do it in a safe
stress-free and economically sensible
way
stay away there's no reason to come to
the strip but the two best choices are
to park here at the convention center
free of charge and take our las vegas
monorail we have a great local special
of two dollars round trip
or if you want to tap into your local
neighborhood we partnered with rtc for
their game day express program that's
similar to the vgk games and the raider
games and we have several distribution
points throughout the valley for four
dollars round trip at one of your
favorite local casinos or downtown
at cashman center the mob museum or
bonneville transit center
3400 people can ride the monorail an
hour and it begins at 7am now the draft
entertainment lineup was also revealed
today and rocky theas has more